so I'll come back to the second part
thanks to the ceilin you have done a
great job in stimulating discussions
over coffee break I should have learned
a lot with my sweet face by ac/dc so
other good discussions so I guess he'll
continue bodies okay great thanks
so this recap I'm sorry we are
interested in the three-phase AC system
and the three concepts key ideas that
allow us between purpose analysis at one
month all right so I'll go through the
device models and then use that amount
of the net
okay so and then we use that to model
the network and the power flow equations
then we can do the math that that we
usually see in research papers okay so I
will try to go through this quickly and
if we don't have enough time and we must
keep some some parts of it so
transmission line so these are the
important devices and there are more
devices but transmission line so what we
would like is eventually get with this
circuit model a transmission line so
this is a standard model for trans
circuit model for transmission line is
called the PI models or exist of SIA
pine-sol these are serious impedance
that's the strong immittance on each end
what this represents is the terminal
behavior the relationship between the
sending end voltage and current and
receiving end voltage and current so you
to think about you have a generator here
they try to transmit power through a
transmission line eventually the power
will arrive at the nose or you connect a
low so typically you specify how much
power you need at the load and at what
voltage level so you specify V true for
example right the power if you specify
the Comcast power you also specify I'm I
to so think of we know V 2 I 2 and we
want to decide what would be the voltage
in the current that will require to
supply the kind of load and therefore we
need a map that map's the receiving end
verbose to the sending in variables so
this would be a circuit model for
transmission line the next ten minute or
so out just goes to how do we divide
this so it's 30 depends on the material
of the line the size of the line how we
arrange the line for example and then
and then get through this and then some
indications of such a model for example
so Finkle we have say three wires three
conductors they're coming out of the
water the current flows these
electromagnetic effects the total flux
linkage for if there's only one line is
related to the currents in the line is
proportional current and this
proportionality constants what we called
inductance if you have multiple lines
then the total flux linkage
corresponding through this line case
line right that would define the
characteristics of this line is given by
this expression so never mind the detail
what it breaks down to is that there is
a factor that depends on the current in
the case conductor and then the a bunch
of electromagnetic effects due to
occurrence at the other conductors in
the dependence is the first the self
inductance depends on the radius of this
conductor so I guess our pie which is
radius times a factor think of that one
and then the mutual inductance from
other conductors carrying current
depends the distance between the Centers
of these two conductors so that's now if
we if we carefully define how we build
these lines for example if we use the
same material for each of the three you
can have the same radius if the distance
are the same the separations between
spares are same then that expression
boils down to this now what is nice
about this is that the faces are
decoupled that the tone of us linkages
in face a meaning that is this line
depends only on the currents in facing
it's not that there's no mutual
interactions among those survives they
are but because of this symmetry
interesting reduce boils down to this
very important law of E which is the
same for all phases and therefore it is
as if the phases do captain
so that's a point now this one key
assumption in this derivation which is
if you look at the current so it gets
Direction some of them and positives on
the Y and negatives and so on the curls
across the conductance the sum is zero
at all time and therefore you've let's
say that the power that you the wires
are used to carry the power to the low
and return for the same path for example
then this is satisfied and therefore we
have the couple of phases but again that
allows us to do per phase analysis
similarly if you look at the capacitance
of each line which is defined to be so
the charge is proportional to voltage
and that constant is capacitive work out
the physics again it boils down to the
the mo th depends not only on the
charged in the case conductor you also
dependent on charges at the other
conductors and if that dependence is in
terms of the distance between the
conductors and again if you carefully
design a while I would be before and
under the assumption that the charge is
all sum to zero then the phase is
decoupled alright so the voltage in a
case conductor depends only on a charged
in the case conductor so and therefore
the mutual interaction has a very simple
structure you ought to say ok so this
defines so in summary if we have this
balanced three-phase line then the faces
that we couple under those assumptions
are reasonable right they return
positive for the same as the fourth path
for example then the line is Kurt rised
by the series impedance where L is what
we saw before the
per meter see the capacitance per meter
and there's this thing due to resistance
or conductance that depends on the
material the kinds of the size of the
area of your wires and so on so each
line then is crushed wide by these two
numbers series impedance and centimeters
per meter right so we know what the
material is when we peeled of line we
know how we arrange them and therefore
we know these two numbers okay so
they're right okay then let's use this
line characteristic to build a circuit
model for the transmission line okay so
what we interested in is the terminal
behavior that is if we specify the
voltage and currents or power at the low
end what is the voltage and currents or
the powers that we need under supply so
we need to map v2 i2 so when we apply a
voltage so this is the surface we will
do all this per phase business and at
the end we get a model that is per face
model this is the voltage to neutral
I remember the phase circuit that we
have so that's that voltage okay so when
we apply a voltage v1 on a supply side
which would drive a current what we
receive here is no longer we want
because of the impedance series
impedance devoted to typically draw we
will currents a typically leak so and
therefore the voltage and current each
point on line it's different are
different so but you pay you can use
this kerkhof law to figure out what what
it is
alright so suppose so you measure this
is zero and then across these states so
at position eight right
if a certain voltage you're selling
current now we know this serious
impedance per meter per unit length and
therefore you can think of this if the
decimal segment of your wire
to have a serious impedance z x DX and
the strong admittance Y times the X and
again zy are the things that we know
from the previous slide we build a wild
stuff we know them and then you can do
this
so we're interesting this math so you
can you can you can write down a
differential e you can write down a
differential equation that relates V and
I with respect to the position solve
that you get something like this
details are not important the point is
one superior line we know these shown
immittance we know the series impedance
that defines these two parameters these
are called characteristic impedance of
the line it's a sub par meter
propagation constant some parameter then
this tool permit defines a linear map
that map's the receiving end voltage the
current to the standing here and
therefore we build a network we know
this matrix we know how a transmission
line behaves and when yes
right okay so think of this as say it
like a resistance then if you apply a
current so the resistance that divides
with two wires you apply a current you
apply a voltage then there's a current
go through it the fat is the current
will heat up the stuff so that that
consumes energy now if this transmission
line that energy that's being consumed
is bad is a loss but if this like off
the traditional dipole
that [ __ ] is good because he or she is
lost but he also gives that light and
Diplo consumes energy so the impedance
you can think of think of this the
simplest thing is here's the resistance
even though for transmission lines
typically resist the wear small there's
more inductance and answer the question
yes so this is this is for low frequency
there's no radio radiative
component to this analysis so if you're
thinking about a little minute so
depends on the model you use they can go
back to the master equations but then
you but now you get well you can think
of this as the approximation of that
very detailed model present so this is
the model that is reasonable for say
understanding steady-state of a power
system but I guess maybe to you the key
thing is that when we apply we connect
generator to transmission that were
eventually to the load right so the
point of the network should carry energy
from that point to that point when you
go to a network say it one transmission
line there will be some energy loss
there's a relation between the power
that you send or the voltage occurrence
on the sending end and the power
received or the voltage and current at
receiving end and the relationship
between what we receive at a loss so it
uses what we want with to be specify
this and what we need to supply at the
end has a very simple linear map in
terms of voltage and current and that
map depends on characteristics where
line that's defined by these impedance
and
so mathematically a transmission line
just a linear map okay so okay so this
is the model that maps v2 to v1 you can
think of this model as a circle like
this so which which means that here's so
this is a circuit diagram sorry
different from what's previous but you
could replace them as some others but
but the typical thing you can think of
that matrice as represented by this
circle where it is a serious impedance
they're stronger meters at each end
for those who could who don't know
second as it doesn't matter
it always is some linear map for those
of you who know the circuit model then
then you can do this circuit nozzle you
write down the cough law then you can
relay you can relay again this v2 i2 to
v1 i1 in a matrix V remember C then you
match this matrix from the circuit
analysis with this matrix and then you
can write down the parameters of your
circuit model where Z prime is Z times a
factor Y prime Y times a factor what is
the my it's simply the total impedance
that depends on the characteristics of
airline impedance per meter times the
length and the total mutants is again
the sum total or the stronger meeting
sense of length with simple okay so for
example the remember it goes all the way
back to this it goes all the way back to
for this so the critic of your line
which depends on materials and styles
and all of that is worth five credit
rise by these three parameters you have
the resistance here the inductance
typically for
hive or the transmission lines and all
that this is very small look this is
going to determine how much Energy's
loss in your transmission network and
therefore you Bill your system so that
is it small for this two two numbers and
these are strong emissions where you can
think of currents lease right as you as
you stand powerful one end to the other
then the current that this is determined
is due to this this is saying that we
call strong remittance
that also has a thing of this like one
over the resistance and then it is the
capacity we see fair so in that circle
model that then you see these four
things
RL you students see artists stuff are
the symbols thing so this is arms I
don't know whether question along be
here you connect alone here but this is
but this model does the e fad of
transmission line when you send power
from say generation to the current to
voltage current nonlinear we will come
back to these powerful equations so now
we're still trying to model this device
transmission line but we eventually will
come to the powerful equations their
models the networks and so on a single
transmission line yes it's called a PI
module because of this thing we shape
okay so so again zmy are the the stuff
that depends on the material and the
length L is the length and and these
things are some factor okay so if you
have a really long transmission line
then the the PI model has as that which
is which is this okay but if the line is
shorter then this is roughly 1 and
therefore all matters is the length of
the line
so so if it becomes more lovely if
you'll still shorter line you can ignore
this they can assume didn't see then you
get this so we saw this diagram before
the transmission line just some serious
impedance and sometimes we even assume
the resistance in the series impedance
zero so it was the inductive but those
are the assumptions eventually get to
some model that we use in power flow
but this is just a model transmission
lines impedance okay right so this is so
basically if you specify this is the
power that you need in this simple
example for example that would specify
the current that I need and the loss
even the transmission line so you can
think of the heat loss here is good it
is is what we use
he lost here is bad this is just to
bring power from the here to here and
that he loss is is proportional to the
current squared current magnitude
squared and this is the resistance of
the line and therefore if we want to
minimize this rarely - the I will use a
very high voltage that's why the in the
transmission line Network voltages are
so high again there's a cause in high
voltage and all of them that's why you
eventually we we come down so the recap
the like roots first it depends on how
we peel the system there's a linear
curve a circuit model yes there's a
bottom line eventually we come down to a
linear circuit per face model that we
use okay transformer so transformer is
the important device because you see all
these different voltages in a network
that is where we need the Transformers
to change the voltage levels and that is
also why ACS have been a dominant
compared with DC is be easy to change
voltage levels so the ideal transformer
is critize by just one number is that
okay so that so so so physically this is
basically to my native core and then you
have wires around the min and the number
of course in each of the primary instead
of your society determines this
parameter end
and that defines the map between the the
primary side or from the left and a
secondary side so so n is the ratio of
the number of coils a T is just one over
there simple is okay you can look at the
power because it's ideal there's no loss
or the power input and output the same
what you put in right now no idea then
there's some sears you Peter there's
some strong mittens and therefore a non
ideal transformer or at least a model of
area is characterized by these three
numbers how the voltage go from primary
to the secondary and then this is
serious impedance and charlatans and
this 20-ton measure you view a device
you twist a measurement you know and you
know this you notice and therefore know
the courtesy of your transformer it is
one things now three things you but
again you can write down a map between
say the sending and the receiving end
voltage occur is a linear so transformer
is a linear device
three things so yeah so this is one
things right so this is one phase you
you have these coils and stuff yes
single phase transformer feel them you
are connecting in some clever way so
this particular connection corresponds
to a Y connection of Transformers on the
primary side the secondary side which is
these coils the way you connect them you
say why configuration students you know
you can do Delta Delta
you can do it out a while even to Y
Delta this is particularly interesting
because you get is boost so for example
the transformer is TV use use for many
many many many purposes but one of them
is to to step of it or step up your
voltage you get a boost off because of
the arrangement
you get a puto square root 3 for free so
that's so that's useful yeah then you
request you could have a Y Delta oh so
in general for ideal transformer
three-phase depending on how you connect
them by if use it why why then the
voltage gain is in against the ratio of
primary to the secondary coil and of
course the current is 1 over N and
therefore P is an ideal power gains 1 if
you connect them in Delta Delta the game
is also in the connected in Delta Y then
it is not n you have a score of 3 tools
and then at 30 degree so the complex
game ok right so the gayest of the
voltage so this is the the voltage on
the secondary sound this n is this gain
time the voltage input
so you apply input voltage the output
will be multiplied by this it's much
bigger factor that's right and the
current is 1 minus 10 but it's complex
number in general depending on look how
you connect them so this one mind one
over the complex conjugate so the power
use the power gain is the product is to
gains with power is V times I so if I
increase voltage by ten times recurrence
reduced by ten times the current powers
more power gains one
so for real transformers so they must
lose some powers over you know how far
away or how close is the bargain to one
for your trust but real I don't know the
number but typically is relatively close
I guess it also depends on how pain and
right if you do a big one then you want
to use materials and everything so that
is small and so so quickly you just
white outer then you get a score you
step down
okay
so again this is interesting for step up
purpose because of square three and
therefore a per face equivalent circuit
transformer is simply you have this non
ideal transformer effect right so that's
what you were asking and then you have
this ideal transformer that's defined by
this general conquer scale and again the
voltage and currents is related to the
voltage currents and the other the
output and secondary side by a linear
map the depends on the the ideal
transformers gain and is this is no idea
offense of the real transformer
okay so again you get a preface model
linear model even to Professor analysis
in a power network that has transformers
so there's one thing that I have to tell
you is that you can do this per union
organization and stuff and the most
transformative Sapir from your circuit
nevermind
so so the recap you keep for three-phase
funds balanced system you could have
different configurations are you studio
scattered in your turf a circuit model
that looks like this I'm going to speed
up
okay so generators I want to say that
she's basically do you typically yeah it
depends depends on the types of models
and so on so you have a voltage and then
you go through a very serious impedance
that that is the terminal voltage that a
network sees sometimes we ignore this
sometimes we swap this as part of the
network this is the terminal voltage
that defines the voltage source okay so
putting everything together suppose we
have a system where we have a
three-phase generators with the terminal
voltage is some bead line going straight
step up transformer going so a
transmission line a whole network with a
single line step-down transformer and
then eventually electric vehicle right
you can write down because parents
operations everything you can write down
the per phase stuff as we did right then
you get 3 phase transformers 3 phase
transmission line step-down transformers
then you get a circuit you can do the
analysis for these parts model the
transformer one set up transmission line
which is the simplest model there's no
PI right so so some of meetings are
ignored if there's a serious impedance
that represents on consumer and then you
have a step-down transformer and angle
oh it's a perfect circle going to second
analysis and then get what you want
it's what if you have many loads
empowered out for example yes yeah yeah
are somehow splitting the power among
them yes could we think of conservation
there so there is conservation power
whether it is additive or not depends on
multiple things depends on for example
the loads are you serious or in parallel
depends of the size of those laws and so
on so you can calculate all of them is
yeah
okay so happy now okay
so right so so now we know how we view
from these physical systems we have
simple mathematical models everything
boils down to parfaits linear right as
far as voltage and currents are
concerned you can use that model a whole
network but willows generators and then
you can use that to formulate opf
problems which again a lot of
applications boys on to solving these
constraint optimization problem so let
me have a little bit about this so
here's one example where you have a
source so this is you can be a voltage
source but there's the equivalent
current source representation where is
the kernels but some source going to a
transformer a line coming through a load
which can be a turn-off constant current
or whatever the point is you use a
three-phase balance you can write down
is per phase circuit or something like
this so the interesting thing is that
between these terminals so all these
paths and this terminal the bunch of
series impedance and Shanno matrons they
may not be equal and all of that so for
example in this transmission line we're
using the simplest model there's no
stronger mutants just
justinian serious impedance or one over
there it's the Y so Y appears here get
the end here because of this regulating
transformer there are some strong
elements in your circuit model that I do
to be the Transformers and so on so and
therefore in general if we have a
network where this is the past so v1 i1
represents this
so on 100 parsec apply a v1 you have a
current i1 goes through a transmission
line go to connect to another bus this
can be a loan or a generator whatever
right so this is a simple network then
get transmission line so this is a sort
of a ideal this is not a physical
transmission line as with so here you
can't have multiple devices yeah they
are modeled by some serious impedance
and shunt admittance and therefore the
this this thing that consists of
basically and maybe a transmission lines
and transformers and whatever devices
can occur twice by three numbers these
are series impedance or one over there
and then there's a shown at each end of
a line and they may be people they're
not necessary to send this may not be
there this is the strong admittance that
critize this connection may not be just
due to the PI model you can do to other
devices in your network but you specify
a network to think of this simple model
you have buses joined by links to Swiss
differentiate that from transmission
line the actual transmission line
connected by links and those things can
be courage wired by three numbers with
specific interpretations equal okay then
with such notation that describes your
network right so these are given these
are not variables one should be with
network in principle we know what these
numbers are then the eight defy a matrix
what's called an admittance matrix is
one that relays the metal currents i1 i2
i3 and the vector voltages v1 v2 v3 the
voltages in the entire network is
related to the current injection in each
pass by this simple relationship
is why matrice is determined by all
those
parameters that we find your links
okay so the point again is that is a
linear system that that if I peel my
network I know this never matrix I know
the relationship between voltage and
current so you can write down what is
the what is the each element of the
matrix you can write this down in terms
of those specifications it's a nice
structure but it specifies a graph
structure and the impedances and
admittances
okay so doesn't matter matrice he is
going to appear in the OPF problem okay
okay right so there's some interest just
go straight down to that using that
matrix which so these are the series
impedance or one over there meetings on
each or each link right again Alain can
consist of lines with transformers and
other devices and water so this defines
a network now what I so so we have
looked at this so this this define this
is never matrix use the voltage curve a
back of all religious in the network and
each node each node here's the current
interested at each node the vector so
that Y defines the network the power so
this is linearly for interested only in
voltage and current if you are
interested in power because my given
needs 30 kilowatt hour then then we need
to define what is that say the law at no
J which is some complex power that
complex power will be related to the
voltage and current at that node by this
so that's the power balance and
therefore if I want to interesting boaty
to incur everything linear well once we
interest in power then you get is
quadratic
so that defines a powerful equation and
we can eliminate I you they may they may
know you get a relationship between the
power injection you think of this as a
generator power generation power how
much your january i think that is the
low how much you need to consume at no J
now you specify this for example then
you want to figure out what is the
voltages that you need and each no but
it can be lemonade
I then it looks something like this you
know something so the power balance
becomes it's you relates the how in
judgment note with the voltages at each
point every note really they're no
connected to no J and that connection is
this
there were matrice so that's compress
form you can write from the polar form
you can write down in terms of voltage
real and reactive it's really magic pipe
and run quadratic form doesn't matter so
is they get a quadratic form that
relates the voltage in the network in
the entire network in a current in the
power right so the challenge typically
is that suppose it's specified as J for
all J that is I know exactly how much
generate H know how much consumed H
knows I know the complex power every J
what is the resulting voltage so I will
solve this quadratic equation amazingly
birdie do is known structurally about
the solution where they has a solution
what is you need and Steven on
comparison but you can America compute
so the power flow problem is roughly
their variations but roughly you specify
this and you try to figure out the
voltage and you say does the voltage
certified the balance so so one very
important approximation of of this model
is what's called a DC power flow it's a
linear model where the voltage magnitude
so if you look at this powerful equation
this is the basic power equation because
one equation you you if you want to
remember one equation this is the one so
it is complex voltage complex voltage we
assume the man who's the same and
therefore the only variable in that
voltage is these things then if we
assume that the face if you assume you
can write you can write so so
essentially you assume the life lost or
so you don't have this time the these
are constant fixed voltage so these are
constant if your sin theta J minus theta
is small then sine is roughly theta J
minus a okay and therefore the easy
powerful is a simple linearization of
this with additional assumptions but you
get a linear linear linear model between
the real power H node and the phase
angle
so this is what I use in for example
running the markets we try to determine
how much each generator to generate and
how to price the electricity each node
this is the model this one used but it
comes from that one okay so the last 20
minutes so now I wish okay so sorry
Cap'n so if we build this network we can
figure out a per face smaadahl for the
network we can write down the network
matrix that describes two Network
topologies and the impedance and
everything and then we have these
powerful equations so for example we
want to figure out so I mentioned at the
beginning that the way we want our
system is with for custom ends so we
know the SJ s that our demand we have to
decide how much each generators to
January when and where so we have to
figure out a problem right so there you
can form a say opf so we'll see that
another example we have a lot of solar
panels that coming up all right so so
the generation so generally fluctuates
the voltage fluctuates and you may exist
to say the legal bounds but you can try
to stabilize the voltage by adjust the
output of the reactive power output of
your so solar panel emergence to try to
stabilize the voltage what is the
optimal way to do to do that you can for
me there's a loop here you have another
example you have a bunch of electric
vehicles and you know how much energy
each one needs what is the time when
they park you know the conditions of the
network what is the optimal schedule for
each charging of v's you can formally
there as an OPM so lots and lots of the
applications points time to disappear
problem and you solve the teeny every
hour every day around the world to
determine
how we operate a network how the price
electricity there's a huge literature
the first time in 1862 and I mentioned
earlier this is the most important model
and it looks something like this we want
to minimize the Southern cause subject
to a powerful equation that's the
equation we saw with some operational
constraint handing on the application
the cost function may be different the
operation constraint may be different
the powerful equations always do
supposedly you can simplify pasame and
all of that is so you look something
like this again details are important
this can be this generation cost when
we've perfect our generation or this can
be user utility when you try to do a
demand response subject to power flow
equations
so this looks different but it's the
same equation we had before but in terms
of voltages you want the line fold will
lie between a certain daemon because if
the line flow is too high the loss on
the lines are too high the temperature
goes up the line set touches the push we
get a fire so to do some constraints on
the line image if this generator then
there's a capacity constraint on how
much you can generate or if it is low
that is specified then you specify the
lower bound goes out per pound so this
becomes a load that's given in the
voltage limit you can have other
constraints but roughly if the structure
is that you want to minimize a certain
cost subject to two sets of constraints
why is powerful equation that's
fundamental you cannot we can only
escape
the others are operational constraints
which often are simple structure in the
challenge is that this matrix is not
positive semi-definite and therefore you
get these non convexity so the variables
here are the voltage phasor for ordered
every point of the network the power
injection therefore in the network and
line flows they can eliminate some of
them but so this is a famous picture
that looks like looks that even if a
simple three bus network the feasible
set can be very strange it's actually
arguable we just said that comfort versa
yes opf heart is np-hard formerly brain
frankly you just don't look well with
them very often you get global solution
so isn't so you're still arguable is opf
heart right not not in the complexity
theory cells okay so how do we do is non
convexity you can linearize you can do
conversation and there are different
kinds of conversations you can do
real-time over here okay so in the last
15 minutes I want to get to this point
okay
[Music]
okay all right Priya stations so a lot
of people contributed this we just tell
you a little bit I mean so so the ideas
were Simone is a Nam for this is OPF
when you delineate the injection you can
write in charge in terms of the voltage
vector it needs a power equation as J
equals this is the powerful equation
that we saw before
Eliminator has strengthened our stead
lies between the upper town then you get
an optimization problem where the berbil
is only the voltage vector so it's
quadratic in the variable is non-combat
qcq key you can do the standard cemetery
immunization think of vvh so everywhere
the voltage verbal appears appears
quadratically at a rate more matrix and
by n matrix and therefore equivalent
problem you think of that matrix as your
variable and therefore in several
quadrat in the very body now you have a
linear in a verbal but not every n by n
matrix is a variable it has to be
positive semi-definite as we ran one so
these two problems equivalent given any
voltage are set by your constraint there
is a matrix a step additional
constraints even in both matrix that
about these constraints here's you need
voltage up to a rotation that side like
that so they're equivalent the non
convexity is here this is linear this is
combat so you you can ignore them all
right so let's just solve the combat
problem without the law they rank
constrain you get your optimal w check
whether the W turns out to have red one
if you have m1 you got a global solution
for T or regional problem otherwise
we're stuck
was the physical meaning of this what
drunk one country in terms of circuit
and this is not tea
I don't know anyone has any inside
for specific simple example that I can
tell you but in general maybe you're not
going to show you a simple example where
which is the physical interpretation of
the constraint in general and therefore
the strategy is that we want to solve
this problem which we don't know how to
solve
you can solve regularization once you
get an optimal solution which is you can
check simple conditions and you're going
to satisfy that you can recover now I
want to tell you one powerful model
there's that another major powerful
model which is really interesting
develop a perfectly I finished school
and his student 89
that's really nice model has a lot of
interesting advantages but time but for
that you can also do similar thing it's
not that rem-1 matrix but gives a
corresponding commercialization ok so
let me just mention one one thing that
if this tree network was called a Radio
Network the tree topology then instead
of solving STP which is how to scale
consists of SOC p ii Vodacom is much
much much faster so it's much faster
computationally but you get the same
tightness as SDP so so really nice
because most marketing innovations are
probably to appear in distribution
systems distribution systems have tree
topology and there has a nice
computational structure
moreover the tree topology are the are
sufficient conditions that guarantee if
we do this second order conversation
it's guaranteed to give you a global
solution for your regional non convex
problem there's not there's no no
sufficient condition for general mesh
network but for tree network there are
sufficient conditions that give a
guarantee realization always works
when frankly as a missionary in Prague
even if those sufficient conditions are
not satisfied very often we recession
does work even though Kuh algorithm
which is much faster but I often give
you the global solution so there's
something in the real network that there
seems to have some nice structure which
we don't really say ok so let me skip
there I will show you one sufficient
condition but let me skip that
so your last 10 minutes let me let me
tell you about some very interesting
work by ETA time is a current class
student PJ was a former postdoc and and
this really started with a little part
of his thesis 50 thesis now in the moon
crank it's not Facebook so the
motivation is that the original
motivation was interesting it came about
in our up a lead project where we try to
understand history of sessions and stuff
and then the Opera you want us to don't
just do smella
which is too simplistic use this clarity
which is very elaborate piece of
software that stimulates the network
much more realistically but none of my
so which means that we have a develop
software and integrating into the quilt
ID code
none of my students wanted to live sorry
ok let's just you school at T as a as a
black box let's just develop algorithms
to optimize on variables that we can
actually control so at the time we were
looking at controlling TVs inverters
tokens and storage so lets developers
and just operate on those devices that
we actually control and then we apply
that control to give that D and just
read off what it gives out and then just
repeat so so it really came up how you
were trying not to not to mess with good
at least code but if you think about
this this is exactly what we can do in
Bruce's
is the only thing we can do we can run
all these offline algorithms compute all
the variables the voltages and line
flows and everything until converges
once we get a solution for all the
bottom variables do something as
variables that we can actually set right
we set the net world and never it's
going to solve powerful equations for us
and determine all the other variables so
really what we can do here is all we can
do in practice the sudden motivation is
that what an error is called so the
computational complex challenges in opf
that we formally comes from powerful
equations we have to somehow increase
rate or its basis solve that the
networks always solving powerful
equations for us in real time and skill
so maybe we can exploit that if we can
do that then you will naturally get
algorithms that would track Network
conditions if the network incision
changes these hopefully will be
reflected in the measurements that we
get from the network so you would so
this will be important closed loop so
it's very much a feedback control
perspective to this optimize the OPF
okay so
so let me just describe the two set up
so the OPF is we want to minimize the
certain costs depending on your
applications whatever the constant is
over to set of variables 1 corresponds
to devices that we actually can control
itself whatever it's set points and the
other ones are the states of the network
that we don't do the edge control so
their line flows in the network the
voltages and at a nose for something
subject to thousand constraints one is a
powerful equation once the other set is
the set of operational constraints so
let's assume essentially impressive
function zeros which means that if we
choose any control at least in this set
here say you need solution wide of X
that's set by this which the never will
compute for us the Assumption if that's
the case then we can substitute every
where the berbil Y appears we can
substitute Y of X so that we get a
problem that's been minimizing over only
X so now this can be conversed in Y but
this becomes Lancome s and X so this is
what the linear constraining why this
becomes nonlinear constraint what we
have is nonlinear non convex
optimization what is interesting is an
interesting without by someone else that
says the feasible set is that she turns
out to be convex anyway so you have this
non convex problem they want to solve
many ways you can solve this one used to
take this constraint which is difficult
today as a penalty or area then you get
to a form where you want to minimize
over it's in a very simple set is
communicate across this mu is parameter
that defines your penalty or barrier so
suppose this is a problem once all
if I understand what you're doing it
seems that the power is being consumed
exactly that without any time delay
exactly as it's being generated so in
reality you might work to generate at
one time store it and then use it so
that you can still formerly within the
same framework then you get variables
that use time and then say this if you
can store then the storage will couple
those variables across time but you will
still be within the same framework you
just have a bigger size
okay so so the idea of this real-time
online fee values that don't solve this
problem until converges and then apply
or control
you just each time step you take a
gradient step apply your control and
then you measure the Y of T and deal
with there's no free lunch we don't have
to solve powerful equations but now I'm
gonna have to do all the measurements
and communications and all of that it's
now clear easier but but that's the
trade-off but of course if you do that
if you can do this there are other
benefits is not just avoiding non
convexity it's really the tracking
that's important in the future when we
have more more uncertainty we really
need to close the loop so so so so this
approach explicitly exploit the network
as powerful solver and you would
naturally trap okay let me just close by
let me escape the static let me just
tell you the tracking part and then we
should be done in a few minutes okay
okay so okay so that's a static opf that
we just went through you can go through
the status eventually get a nonlinear
equation in X only right the suppose the
OPF also changes so each time step you
take a gradient step you apply to the
network that never changes you get a
different opf that depends on T so it's
a time varying OPF I mean they're
variations where you can do use that one
iteration apply you can do ten you trace
in the plan itself is simply did we
think of each time step you take one
gradient step apply to the network the
network changes you get a measurement of
YT you compute a nice gradient step and
you repeat so the question is asked the
time varying opf progresses how about
does he track so so right so well first
of all they are with them doesn't trap
my house so let's do a second order
right so this is hessian over some
approximate right so the same seven each
time t you take a gradient step you
apply to the network never was so
powerful you question you get the
measurement why that was allowing you to
compute the gradient step and then how
long does it traps well suppose suppose
in each time t you gotta opiate somehow
you figure out the optimal solution for
that home PF at time T is any local out
local optima or global optimum this is
the XT that you generate using this you
look at the controller
time averaged so that's the how well you
turn then you can thicken so that it it
depends on three things in visual space
not surprising it depends on how fast
the OPF changes over time as represented
by for example how the optimal solution
for each
panty opf evolves in a static that you
guys soon
this has to do with time t minus one you
get as you you make a you make a
gradient step right the time T then the
problem changes maybe the feasible set
changes the point that what's peaceful
in t minus one is no longer feasible so
you need to do something so and so this
captures said he also captures how far
is this initial point from the optimal
time T so again all these are measures
of how fast your opf changes over time
the second factor it depends on the
error in your approximation is exactly
and then the condition and therefore if
the prom doesn't change fast
if the problem is well conditioned and
if there's no error in your computation
then you test well it's not too
surprising okay so let me just close
with these are some simulations you can
see that the two curves on the costs why
is the optimal cost one see how well did
you trust very well basically but of
course there's a lot of a lot of
challenges underlying this curve this is
certainly not soft it is a lot of open
okay so let me close with you so
hopefully in the future we'll have a
large net of distributed energy
resources and at least for some
applications we will need to do a
real-time decision and very often one of
the computational challenges is due to
the powerful equations which we cannot
escape from
and yet the network gives solving this
maybe we can explore it and we should do
that we'll get it out and then naturally
tracks so that's important for the for
the for the for the so it's you can do
that so hands go to the past heart scale
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
so how it's interesting using the
network to kind of give you a useful
solution for free how do you combine
this with the desire to plan ahead
you're using storage injections so we
haven't looked at that and you this I is
you may not be the simple question but
one obvious thing you can do is they
okay suppose you have some forecast data
you can formulate that within the same
frame right but then there's all sorts
of issues on forecasts and how do you do
the forecast was the errors will the
error propagates in one of them but
there will be one over think of try
first but I think this is open there's a
lot of challenges which we don't find
this day in this real time or time
variable PFE
with the OPF problem be formulated for
the single problem you did so for the
whole grid but then the whole grid
depends on your application so for
example you find interesting in let's
say I have a garage on the UV charging
and I want to optimize the typing
process but also with respect also
providing say demand response energy
services to degree right so when I do
the GV charging I can optimize the
charging process not only for the use of
benefit of the user but also I can help
say stabilize the voltage on the feeder
on that part of the network then my
garage connects to their has a lot of
solar and they've devoted for choice now
in that problem I can formulate Nokia
then the network would try to speed that
one feeder or a small part of the fields
now if I'm thinking about was Kaname
dispatch where you try to decide the
generation then the network okay the
clear answer is that we don't understand
all this saga issue one thing we observe
is exactly one of the devotees that you
alluded to which is you can be tracking
a local optimum and then the problem
changes that no cotton disappear yeah so
the dog has an interesting issues which
we don't really have a good crap okay
let's X deal for a beautiful two
lectures
[Applause]
moving back here at